[Music]
the minor actor from the king of queens
becomes a groveler in mom jeans
yeah he's the friend from hell for
selling out chappelle
comedian patton oswalt has apologized
for being friends with dave chappelle
after performing with his longtime pal
on new year's eve yeah it looks like
when the balls dropped patins
disappeared
look at him what happened oswald he
looks like joe devito's grandmother
i don't even know what she looks like
it's probably hotter than that though
sorry joe i didn't mean to
objectify your probably dead grandmother
oh anyway apparently
they were doing shows
they were doing shows next door to each
other i mean she might be alive but we
don't know
they were doing shows friday night in
seattle when oswald got a call to join
uh dave's show and oswalt wrote uh why
not i waved goodbye to this hell year
with a genius i started comedy with 34
years ago
i ended the
year with a real friend and a deep laugh
can't ask for much more well it turns
out oswald could ask for much more
namely approval from strangers online
who saw the photo with chappelle didn't
approve so oswald put up another post
which reads in part
i'm an lgbtq ally i'm a loyal friend
there's friction in those traits that i
need to reconcile myself and not let
cause feels of cause cause feels a
betrayal in anyone else whatever and i'm
sorry truly sorry that i didn't consider
the hurt this would cause or the depth
of that hurt
so an old friend did oswalt a favor by
letting him come join his show then
oswald groveled before strangers while
throwing chappelle under the bus all to
scrape up some relevance on instagram a
comic hasn't used another like that
since tom arnold married roseanne
that's what friends are for right
wrong you'd have to be a real clown to
do that right professor sniffles
unfortunately this kind of treachery is
common in the entertainment business
sure there's a comic i helped get his
start back when he didn't know a whoopee
cushion from whoopi goldberg
i said kid you want to spend your whole
career performing for five people in the
back of a pizza place
or would you rather perform for 10
people in front
like me
did i get any thanks
no
more like a giant novelty-sized shoe in
my ass
[Music]
joe mackey
thanks for nothing
fight the real enemy
illinois
well i'm gonna go to you joe you know i
i was i was when this whole thing was
unfolding it was probably the biggest
story of the night
people were going crazy
he was oswald was close to doing
something magical like he could have
served as an example to everybody else
by sharing the risk with his old friend
and saying you know screw you i'm not
gonna apologize but he didn't
it was almost as though like he was
gonna everybody knew he was gonna
apologize right yeah there was a
teachable moment there but it wasn't the
moment that he thought it was and it
wasn't teaching what he thought it was
yeah
look people have posted photos with me
that they later regretted yes
they were family photos
but this was so lame to do this there's
so many things he could have done
differently the first thing he could
have done was not reply to any of it
right that's the way you handle this you
let it go away and then they move on
like any other bully they move on to
someone else who responds and gives them
that juice that they need so what he
should have said was and this is really
sad that
30 something years of friendship and to
to sacrifice it for the uh the approval
of a mob of people that you don't even
know it's really lame and it doesn't
work that's the most frustrating part is
that it doesn't matter what kind of an
ally you are or or what your your stated
opinions are when they set their sights
on you and it's your turn in the barrel
there's nothing you can do about it yeah
you know and kat joe's point is is well
taken that like he actively had to go
look for the problem like like it was
like he
he he doom-scrolled the comments yes to
find to find the sorrow that forced him
to do this that's a that's a certain
type of human being and i don't want to
be i don't want to kick him while he's
down but what an idiot yeah stupid jerk
wow for something howard loser
trash bucket
anyway would you can i the bigger
question cat is and i think you're
thinking it too would you defend me
no matter what horrible disgusting
political opinion i hold i think i do
i'm still sitting here yeah it is true
don't forget it yeah i you won't let me
um but like 34 years seems like a really
long time to be i mean again i haven't
been alive that long so i don't know but
it seems like a really long time
to be a friend of someone and be like i
need you know what i need these
strangers opinions on what kind of guy
that he is exactly and the even weirder
thing is can we show that photo that was
with his apology he posted this photo
with his apology where did this picture
come from like did he take it for this
or did he go through his camera roll
like where's my most thoughtful looking
journaling
picture that i can post very strangely
yeah like who took this and when oh my
god on the other hand in this picture it
looks like
dave chappelle were the world's oldest
make-a-wish kid
[Laughter]
why so many notebooks yeah i would say
i'd say like i actually feel like it's
it's worse okay i feel like not only
should he not have apologized he should
have said the truth which is that dave
chappelle's special the very things he
said on that special we're more positive
and more supportive and will do actual
more measurable
benefit to the trans community than
anything all those like uh online
commenters will ever do like it isn't
not just that dave chappelle should be
allowed to say what he said he actually
moved the issue of trans rights forward
and the i we're living in such a crazy
world now that no one recognizes it he
shouldn't have just said oh sorry or not
said anything he should have he should
have slapped back and said no this guy
did more for that community than anybody
else has done in years you're such a
turf i am
except for the r part you know can i say
what
what does r stand for i forgot radical
radical but you are feminist i'm a term
right handed yeah but by the way wait uh
nick uh before you your important point
is thank you you have a theory don't you
have a theory a patent oswald theory
you'd like to share with america our
millions of viewers
i think that you are the second oswald i
think you are his aspiration like you
know people come in different kind of
vague categories
and you're at the apex of the category
that includes patent oswald there you go
so it's it's uh there are two oswalds so
he's jealous of you everything he does
they cannot try and you know and try to
to supplant you um that's it would you
have another theory uh yeah now the one
thing that i take out of situations like
this which i find great comfort in
because you know at rock bottom i'm just
an internet troll like everybody else
um the fact that celebrities
entertainers politicians leaders the
pope even the pope gets into the
comments on twitter and on instagram and
it is a great world to live in where you
cannot say anything without immediately
getting a million comments telling you
to go to hell yeah and you feel a need
that you have to engage them that's a
structural change from 20 or 30 years
ago and i think it's quite beautiful
well it it it it plays off kind of a
human need like like
for some reason there's a and cat will
back me up there's a greater need to
read the criticism than the compliment
even though you claim you like the
compliment the criticism has a five
times stronger pool
like you want if if there's two boxes
and this one you know is negative and
this one's positive you're gonna open up
the negative one first yeah it hurts
more yeah it has a little bit more of a
sting to it yeah and it's like you said
it's amazing that people have that power
now to change because you know back in
the day you had to send a letter bomb
yes you had to put in some effort tell
me about it just think that you didn't
blame the unit
the unabomber would have just been a
great tweeter
you know that's an interesting point we
would have had fewer assassinations if
we had social media
i don't know if that's true
but it sounds like a provocative idea
for a salon article i was contemplating
maybe it'll be on slate
i get salon and slate confused the way i
get confused with the daily beast in a
huge pile
no one's mentioned that patton oswalt
played a rat
a talking rat a talking racking rat now
talk about that talk about
self-fulfilling prophecy am i right
america you're right greg hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else